hey I'm ready
my name is Bailey and this is my boy
Ethan you enjoying the breeze Bostock
I've lived a lot of lives as a lot of
different dogs but I always found my way
back to Ethan now that isn't getting any
easier that is getting any easier
this is CJ the greatest new addition to
our pack hmm there's nothing in that Cup
I love mornings with our granddaughter
so did I mostly because she gave me
bacon you ever taking a bath with the
filthy dog I just having fun
Oh CJ's mom wants to play too or not
pretty soon CJ had to move away let us
know where you wind up I wanted to chase
the car but I just didn't have the
energy Bailey you've done so much like a
comeback take care of DJ she needs you
like I needed you and then it happened I
was a puppy again and CJ was my new
purpose she was a gigantic baby now
it it you hope to be the authority lay
down what is she saying no idea cj5 a
date tonight
again I could always tell when my girl
needed me as soon as I can I'm getting
out of here
then I moved to New York City wait I
smell my boy really thank you what makes
you think you can just show up like this
we want to see our granddaughter please
you just keep taking care CJ you didn't
get up for anything no matter how many
lives it took I would not therefore CJ
oh hello where did you come from like he
chose you
things don't always turn out as we plan
but sometimes the surprises are the best
part not your drum baby don't stop
beating
there's lots you don't know about that
dog
[Music]
and for
I don't have all the answers
but I know we end up where we're meant
to be like a drum my heart never stops
beautiful
[Music]